let's go to ifti from Germany ifti from
Germany welcome to the program what is
on your mind today
yes I can
excellent you actually got a three in
one actually I'm an Israeli doing a PhD
about populism on Japan in Germany so
let's uh here I'm increasing your
International uh uh cut of the of the
pie today I guess have you seen have you
seen the fourth season of fauda
uh I'm not a big fan of of fauda or wow
it's coming out of Israel I know I also
hate olives I'm I'm ruining everything
for all Israelis I guess I I can I
recommend it to you it's it's a great
season 50 but go ahead okay uh I'd like
to actually make one small comments in
one of your previous uh uh commentators
because
um first of all I'm a big fan of you in
general uh just get together the way uh
he spoke about Pete budage and why is he
electable and I've noticed it's
something that you've discussed a couple
of times I'm I'm not a big fan of this
whole argument that he's not Progressive
enough because I I'm myself I'm a Social
Democrat and I'm considering myself on
the left of of him to an extent okay
um but at the same time
I think you need to look at the field of
who's the most electable and who has a
very good shot and then as like you said
the means and and package uh to win the
presidency and out of those at least in
my view
um if he is elected president he will
probably be the most Progressive
president uh in the history of the
United States I agree with that 100
percent
uh the discussion about Elizabeth Warren
doing the less primary is that uh after
she a couple of her statements a lot of
the people who are supporters of Bernie
uh kind of
criticize her for not being left is
enough and she I think ideologically
she's not to the right of senders uh in
terms of policy and she is probably the
most leftist senator in living memory uh
or most Progressive in terms of social
democracy well there's Bernie
but together with him they're probably
the most Progressive and if arguably the
most Progressive Progressive senator in
In Living memory is not Progressive
enough for you as a candidate
I think this is a possibly a bigger
problem 50 you're making a very good
point that this is a very good point
which is while on Paper Pete Buddha
judge may not be the most Progressive
person in the world if he were president
he would be the most Progressive
president in history that's very I I I
find it hard to argue against that I
think you're completely right
okay
um about the main thing I have two
questions I hope to get them through one
of them is more Technical and one of
them I'm just interested in your opinion
sure uh I'm wondering about the
um the deficit ceiling and the
discussions about it you have all these
discussions on how uh catastrophic and
apocalyptic it will be if the
Republicans will not raise the debt
ceiling yes to my understanding it's
more of a technical issue uh and the
Republicans at the end of the day they
only have a very slim majority uh of
four or five people I have very very low
um expectations of the Republicans but
to say that you would not find four to
five Republicans out of all House
Republicans who would not be willing to
side with Democrats just to do the
technical
um effect of raising the debt ceiling it
sounds very implausible to me it sounds
like more of a talking point than
something that's realistic I'm wondering
if I'm missing something on the
technical level there you know I I don't
know I don't know if you would be able
to find four or five I mean it's really
it's a predictive question it would be
something we're just guessing about I
don't know who the four or five would be
but it's certainly possible that you're
right
okay
uh the last thing again I'm wondering
about your opinion
um as as a person who's ideologically a
Social Democrat for for many years now
I'm wondering how do you deal with
talking points from your own sides that
they don't really make that much sense
and every rational person from your side
that you're tackling with them would
probably acknowledge that they don't
make sense but they're it's it's kind of
a taboo to to bring them up because it's
it's against the cause of of your side
like what I'm gonna give you two two
examples
um one of them if you perhaps know a
little bit about uh what's going on with
the um nursing strikes in the UK at the
moment
that there are all those correct
arguments that the nurses there had
their wages eroded and that they're
being overworked and all of those things
which are completely supporting but one
of the talking points there which is
repeating is that uh NHA workers are
forced to go to food banks yeah and the
median income of an NHS worker in the UK
to my understanding is about 40 000 a
year
40 000 pounds
for forty thousand dollars it's about 32
to 34 000 pounds a year okay and
um
I mean it's
it unless you're a single parent living
in London uh I don't really see how this
kind of seller Which is far above the
like the median or above the median wage
in the UK would mean that you will have
to go to food banks now if you are a
single uh a single uh bread maker living
in London it's not really a a systematic
issue it's it's a specific
problem with their wages in London for
single parents another example is the
debate about the minimum wage in the
United States which I'm always very
confused about you have these talking
points going from I think 2008 about 15
uh minimum wage
um and to me it's even if you look at
inflation over the last
um two years or less year even this
should have changed dramatically so this
insistent of selling this talking point
of 15 minimum wage
it it doesn't really make any sense
because it it's not relying on anything
like an index of living or some kind of
system to keep wages affordable other
than selling this talking point which
which sells I got you I got it yeah
listen these are uh the fine examples I
I don't know enough about food stamps in
the UK food banks in the UK to be able
to weigh in too much I think on the
minimum wage thing it's a very fair
point that the fifteen dollars that was
talked about three years ago is a lot
less money in purchasing power terms
because of the inflation of the the last
three years I completely agree let me
devote some more thought to it okay
okay I appreciate it there is ifti from
Germany and that is going to do it for
us today we will take calls again on all
of the important issues that the fine
folks in the audience bring to me I will
speak to you soon we'll take a quick
break and be right back